a new project in Alabama reflects on one
of the most difficult periods in
American history thousands of
african-american men women and children
were killed by lynching in the decades
after the Civil War this new Memorial in
Montgomery was spearheaded by Bryan
Stevenson founder and executive director
of the equal justice initiative 60
minutes special contributor Oprah
Winfrey visited the memorial with him
for Sunday's 60 minutes here's a preview
so you start with the mid I level and
then on this quarter they begin to rise
and then you get to this corridor and
this is when you begin to confront the
scale of all of these lynchings whoa
this is something yes yes we wanted
people to have a sense of just the scale
with this violence with this terrorism
so this is over 4,000 yeah that had been
documented but of course there are more
thousands more thousands more thousands
more and we ever even know how many we
will never know every name has its own
story yes that's right this was a
minister
Reverend TA Allen who began talking to
sharecroppers about their rights and
because he was doing that the plantation
owners the the landowners got together
and they they lynched him and the proof
they used that he was somebody worthy of
lynching is that when they found his
body he had a piece of paper that talked
about sharecropper rights and the other
piece of paper he had in his suit jacket
was a note that said every man a king a
lot of these folks were lynched because
they showed too much dignity they showed
too much humanity he just wanted to be
respected as a human being and it got
him hanged respected as a human being
you can watch Oprah Winfrey's full
report Sunday night on 60 minutes right
here on CBS she says it's very painful
and sobering and you just looking at
that gives me goosebumps to know what
that represents that it was a time of
celebration for some people let's go and
watch a lynching they're sitting there
eating and watching and cheering yeah
very sad I can't wait to see her spine
Stephenson as a for 70 years
having really important work